you are back now in the studio but you
don't have a studio audience yet
i'm very relieved
that through that whole election cycle
we didn't because so much of it was so
dark it was so bleak trying to talk
about that in front of 200 people
i don't think would have been fun and
particularly our audience which is
the audience that we find in our studio
quite a lot of young
kids quite a lot of teenagers early 20s
quite a lot of tourists
who've come to la who they don't know
about if ted cruz has taken a trip to
cabo
you know what i mean they don't they
don't know and so
sometimes previously
i would tell these and i'd be telling
these jokes to a group of people who are
like
i don't even know the story let alone
get the joke
you know you're gonna do a seven-hour
setup you know yeah and they'd be like
why are you doing this i thought we was
just like a really fun
time you know so it's um
so going through that election cycle i
did find it incredibly liberating
actually
to just be talking to our crew because
at first we did the show in my
garage literally a few feet from where
i'm sat right now
and that was not fun that was really
unpleasant
being completely in isolation i was
wondering how cooperative cbs was
the bosses that i have and
just the way that we sort of run our
show i couldn't be more
supportive actually i i couldn't give
you
one place where they've fallen down and
i might like
look we we sort of talk [ __ ] about them
all the time on the show but like deep
down it all comes from a place of
of genuine love i mean there's a weird
thing happening which we talked about
last night on the show where obviously
steven's show is on before hours he's in
new york
he had like i guess his audience holds
600 people
masterless you know all vaccinated
cheering in a theater
and we're still having being in our
studio no audience with masks on
because we abide by a west coast
cbs viacom i don't know what the [ __ ] it
is
thing i have no idea but if i'm honest i
quite enjoy
that bit of fun that we can have i feel
like our role as that 12 30 show
is to be a sort of
juvenile younger brother who's just like
we're gonna try and have as much fun
here as possible